[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: What if Google
Cloud Platform's machine
learning tools were all
part of one pyramid?
Literally, as I was trying to
fall asleep, I had an idea.
I'm Sara Robinson, and I'd
like to help you figure out
which ML Tool is right for the
problem you're trying to solve.
Google has a bunch of
different ML products
to get you from
point A to point B--
in order to provide flexibility
in choosing which path
you want to take, based
on your cost effort
and speed requirements.
So I wrote it all
out really quickly.
Then, I edited it the
next day and sent it out.
I guess it resonated.
The idea is, as you
move up the pyramid,
less ML expertise is required.
And you also don't
need to worry as much
about the infrastructure
behind your model.
The pyramid is organized
by levels of abstraction.
Let's start at the bottom.
At the lowest level
of abstraction,
we have these
popular open source
machine learning frameworks.
If you're building a model from
scratch using these frameworks,
you get the flexibility
of moving your workloads
across different development
and deployment environments.
As a result, you need to
manage all the infrastructure
yourself, for
training and serving.
If your team has
very specific needs,
and you have the ML engineers
and data scientists,
you might prefer the
total flexibility
of using these open source
ML frameworks on their own
and figuring out where
to train and serve them.
Moving up one tier, Deep
Learning Virtual Machines
provide managed
click-to-deploy VMs
for processing data and
training your model.
These VMs come with
popular ML frameworks
pre-installed, but leave you to
figure out exactly how you'll
serve those models.
For instance, you could
serve them on-premise
or directly on a mobile device.
With Deep Learning VMs,
you can reduce the overhead
of managing and allocating the
compute and storage resources
required for ML workloads.
Kubeflow is an
open source project
created by Google
for deploying your ML
workloads on Kubernetes.
You use it to configure
a multi-step ML pipeline,
with different components
for pre-processing data,
training, and
serving your model.
Because it's open
source, you can run it
on-premise or on AnyCloud.
The other way of saying that
is, what you'll still need to do
is configure where it's managed.
With Kubeflow, you can leverage
the power of containers
to make your ML stack
portable, reducing
the operational overhead
of running your workloads.
AI Platform takes this "where"
question out of the equation.
It's all handled on Google
Cloud Platform, our managed
service for all your
custom model needs.
AI Platform is
entirely server-less,
so you can focus on your
specific workloads and business
logic.
The platform includes tools
for training and serving
models, post to Notebooks,
a data-labeling service,
and more.
For example, you could
take the same Notebook
code you're running
on-premise with Kubeflow,
and run it on GCP with
AI Platform Notebooks.
And something else
I should mention,
you don't have to use AI
Platform for both training
and serving.
If you wanted, you could let AI
Platform handle one, and figure
out the other on your own.
For example, you could take
advantage of AI Platform's TPUs
to train your model, and
then serve it on-device.
By the time we get to
BigQuery Machine Learning,
you no longer need a team of ML
engineers and data scientists.
But it might still be
helpful to have a few.
Unlike the products
below it, with BQML,
you don't have to write any
of the underlying model code.
You'll still need to
choose which model
type you want to use, when you
run your create model query.
Running this query will
create and train your model.
And once you run it, your model
will be automatically deployed
for you, and available
to make predictions
with a single SQL query.
With BQML, you can
bring the power of ML
closer to where the
data is analyzed
and make it accessible
to data analysts.
But what if you didn't
need to write model code
or choose your model type?
That's where AutoML comes in.
All you'll need to do is
gather and upload your data,
whether it's images, video,
text, or structured data.
Then, once you press the Train
button and training completes,
your model is immediately
available for prediction
via an API.
You don't need to
deploy it yourself.
You can also use AutoML's UI
to evaluate your model quality
and update training data.
AutoML democratizes
machine learning
by empowering more
people to build custom
ML models that solve a wide
variety of business problems,
regardless of ML expertise.
For both AutoML and the
tip of the pyramid, APIs,
you don't need any ML
engineers or data scientists
on your team--
just a handful of developers.
What makes our APIs
different from AutoML,
though, is that you don't need
to supply any training data
yourself.
Just make an API
Request, and you'll
get access to pre-trained models
for images, video, speech,
text, and translation.
Our ML APIs are the easiest
and fastest way to get
started with AI today.
I'm Sara Robinson.
And hopefully you're
not losing any sleep
over choosing the machine
learning tool that's
going to help you the most.
Leave that part to me.
Be sure to check out the
GCP YouTube channel for more
relevant informative content.
And if you found this
helpful, don't be
afraid to like and subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[THEME MUSIC]